elle la grande salle où se tient la
journée défense et citoyenneté est
actuellement bien vide depuis le 2
novembre dernier les jeunes ne sont plus
accueillis à la caserne d'artaud à 2
versailles la gdc se fait en ligne
depuis le 23 novembre le jeune valley se
connecter il va remplir vérifier déjà
ces données administratives remplir un
questionnaire et ensuite suivre donc
1 les modules en ligne kiki qui passent
en direct
et puis remplir à la fin questionnaire
de satisfaction de stars va donc le tout
qui dure à peu près de deux heures elle
les agents prennent contact avec ceux
qui n'auraient pas fourni l'adresse mail
une fois convoqué les jeunes en 11 jours
pour suivre le jdc une journée
obligatoire
c'est la troisième étape du parcours de
citoyenneté après l'enseignement de
défense qui est dévolue en classe de
troisième et de première et après le
recensement qui est à accomplir par les
jeunes en leur mairie de domicile entre
16 ans et 16 ans être au moins la jdc
comporte trois objectifs principaux
l'explication des enjeux de défense la
justification des enjeux de défense
puisque nous sommes le troisième poste
après le remboursement de la dette et
éducation nationale et enfin et surtout
l'enjeu de cohésion sociale par la
détection des jeunes qui sont dits
décrocheurs et chaque année 70 mille
jeunes suivent une journée défense et
citoyenneté au service national de
versailles
les journées en ligne se tiendront
jusqu'au 10 décembre prochain